because some people have been asking me
uh
what cyberpunk looks like on an xbox on
original xbox one
and uh
i i actually have video of it this check
this out
original xbox one by the way not the
xbox pro x or whatever
i think you guys are really gonna this
is cool shoot to choose a location
cyberpunk
everybody freeze cyberpunk
cyberpunk
oh boy not both of the erics are in the
chat and they're fighting air france
goes i've always been cool eric
you guys fight to the death cyberpunk's
pretty good on the xbox one though right
cyberpunk
cyberpunk
free sucker cyberpunk
plug him up go shoot me
pretty cool huh what do you guys think
of the cyberpunk
so this is the game they had in the
arcade called crime patrol
shoot to choose a location
so it was basically a video was like one
of the laser shooters um
and this is amazing
[Music]
cyberpunk
[Music]
sir i told you you can't film here this
is an airport garage
i'm gonna have to ask you to leave
[Music]
okay hold on wait a second i'm sorry i'm
gonna back up here
just for a second now maybe ck could
tell me this because he's the nerd but
um i'm not a physics major
and i'm not a fake doctor like jill
biden however
is this what happens when you get shot
[Music]
do you just go flying
did you just go go flying through the
air like that
[Music]
[Music]
cyberpunk
[Music]
let's kick butt i'll take the left
cyberpunk
[Music]
shoot him shoot him shoot him he's
he was probably stealing things you'll
find a gun on him
okay hold on a second uh we have to
point something out here just i'm sorry
don't you
it's um
is that guy wearing blackface
i mean i like that they this cyberpunk
is pretty cool
because they really want you feeling
depth of the criminal mind so the
graphics are great
but he's definitely wearing blackface
right
that's not ted danson specialist it's
not it's not ted danson you would know
because whoopi goldberg would be there
just look at look at the
it's so you can't see him that good
royce uh that's right
unless he smiles old joke
kobe
um that's blackface though for sure you
can tell because he's the governor of
virginia
it's robert downey jr
it's judy garland it's c
thomas howell
it's jimmy kimmel
it's sarah silverman
i could keep going funny how a lot of
these woke people used to hold that
done blackface bits huh we already said
ted danson
one of the cannons already black so like
you can't blackface a blackface it's
double blackface
well wayne brady's black okay doesn't
count
bill cosby again also black and black
it's justin trudeau thank you it's
justin trudeau
let's go down the list of blackface come
on let's go
roddy pi half a roddy piper
half a roddy piper done
jesus christ closer well they couldn't
hire an actual
person they might steal something
[ __ ]
holy [ __ ] clothes are running over hoes
with their wheelchair jesus christ
coming in with the heat
[Music]
[Applause]
oh oh it's shirley temple
be careful guys this the acting is great
i have to watch it again
oh this thing will fry you careful that
digg will fry you it's the only thing
keeping the raptors out
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
somebody said the lady from the view
which one
okay are they are they all wearing
blackface oh
this thing will fry
[Music]
yeah yeah they're all wearing blackface
oh no wilhelm scream
oh bro that's frying him she warned you
that it would fry you
[Music]
i like that they just got a [ __ ] the
biggest trucker hat they could find and
just like put a pin on badge on her
on her hat and her her hat badge doesn't
even match her shirt badge that she got
from the party store
where is that backup
i'm assuming there's guys hiding behind
the boxes someone's gonna fall through
why aren't they bleeding i'm noticing
that they're not that they're not
bleeding at all
why couldn't they have the security
guard to be the cop he looks more like a
cop than the woman does
boxes are bulletproof these these are
hey why don't they make the whole plane
out of the box
am i right guys no but seriously folks
welcome to undercover pick an assignment
uh i'm obviously gonna pick the strip
club
who would pick anything but the strip
club
this guy didn't pick the strip club
there they come the deal's going down
this is agent rodriguez
she's inside
is she because she looks like she's at a
halloween party and nice bangs by the
way
[Music]
bro guys this is for the fellas
look how sick that corvette is that is a
sick ride so sick [ __ ] sick
let's um
you're not being very stealth sir
eat their lunch
[Music]
i think i can do a better line than that
let me try it again
[Music]
it's detective merch
um come on it's not funny guys
let's eat their lunch
[Music]
hey that guy has bla oh that's just a
black guy
[Music]
let's take them okay come on
this guy's an undercover cop
[Music]
you're clearly a cop sir we could all
see you're a police officer what
undercover are you doing
uh hey listen i don't care if ron
bennington wears a fake mustache or not
i know that's you ronnie
take him
i lost my piece but take the point wait
i'm sorry i gotta hear that acting again
this is gonna be happening a lot during
this i wanna hear that acting again
[Music]
i lost my piece but take the plane
i lost my peace but take the plane i
lost my piece but take the plane
i lost my peace but take the plane
i wouldn't shoot at the plane you're
about to get into
here you go director's wife
winners
[ __ ] man this is awesome
no that's evidence you don't just shoot
guys again
not a cop here but you don't
please explain him please somebody help
me out here again maybe one of my lawyer
friends can help me out
uh graphics are so real it's the new
cyberpunk are you supposed to shoot
the evidence are
is that correct it's terrible it's
terrible
after them you're a good point
this is a great episode of five ish this
is the best episode of fiverrs i've seen
[Music]
oh no a woman driving that's the most
dangerous thing that's happening in this
video
[Music]
oh hold on wait a second i'm sorry
okay hold on they were nowhere near a
construction site what happened
look see on a regular road regular road
regular road
shoot the driver oh look a construction
site
in a different part of town
this game is really good i'm so excited
i'm enjoying this i'm gonna keep
watching this you guys fine with keep
watching
i'm enjoying this
welcome to undercover the strip club
god damn it yo this
ain't no restaurant man you got the cash
yo this is no restaurant i mean you got
the cat you can tell that guy's a bad
guy
because he's mad you got the document
she had beauty new id number
it works it works well here's the work
you're under arrest for selling stolen
property
but nothing's happened why is he ready
to run
what he why did he why did he start
running before the guy took a gun out
it works well here's the work
you're under arrest for selling stolen
property why is he running why did he
start
running before guys this game isn't
great
[Music]
i like the freezing since it's a
shooting game they have to freeze and
[Music]
cut
[Music]
[Music]
how many bullets do you ever have to
reload your gun
[Music]
i lost my piece take the plane
[Music]
oh
he he fell on a pad you could see you
could see the pad
you can you can see the
pads right there guys do you under the
take because
do another take i can see the pad
welcome to undercover pick an assignment
strip club
nice now it's marsh
for sure because it's a strip club
hi lulu the usual thanks
hi spencer how are you how you doing
is he drinking a yoo-hoo
that's big tony the tongue tagliano up
there he's a cold-blooded killer we've
been after him for years
oh my god even sounds like him i don't
think he's made us yet
tony shut up how you literally
look like a cop in everything you're
walking in screaming cop
bambi i feel the heat and it's not the
kind of heat i like
is that donut eating gum shoot with a
partner yeah donate a gum shoe with a
partner
i'm an actor oh wow the acting is
really good in this i mean this is the
net this is like
burdemic level of acting
oh my god this generic mobster stuff
take them boys
oh yeah this is a strip club where
strippers don't take their clothes off
it's one of those
special strip clubs it's this is one of
those pg-13 trip clubs when you have to
like
make a pg-13 movie in a strip club
shooter who gives a [ __ ]
why would you stand up and say don't
shoot also
question why are the other guys sitting
there looking at the stripper not
completely running away because
guns are being fired in their direction
yeah this is a lifetime strip club
desert is right why are the strippers
still dancing
again it's a guy standing there
strippers you're having bullets fired
your way
get him they got him they got him
wait a second
is that a stripper or a criminal
trick question it's the same thing
hey you're looking for me not really i'm
looking for a better actor is there one
maybe behind you
that we could get
so i'm so
what year are these gangsters from the
80s or the 1880s i can't tell by the way
they're dressed
shoot her too for good measure
so handsome come here often
you're part of a criminal conspiracy
you can't just hit on the cop
i don't care what cassandra from wayne's
world says
don't listen to her she's part of the
mob